just us trying to keep the city safe
were barely getting it done we do bring
variable there is an answer for every
question let's bring our boy home to
keep my keys
I made you a new suit I'm gonna take it
for a spin
hey everybody the flash is almost back
they're dropping new promos there's
gonna be New York Comic Con this week so
there's a whole bunch of stuff that we
need to break down starting with the
flash season four if you didn't know all
of the DC TV shows are coming back next
week my video schedule is gonna change a
little bit from last year so no worries
flash stuff will always be on Tuesdays
that isn't going anywhere
he'll still be the flash ring giveaway
that I'll do every week but when Justice
League tickets go on sale that's what
the giveaway will be for I'll explain at
the end of the video how that's gonna
work but starting with the big stuff
first they've started to do a bunch of
interviews about how Barry's going to be
affected how his return will change the
Speed Force with the reverse flash is
doing why the thinker needs Barry and
doesn't want to hurt him in what's going
on with some of the other characters so
it's gonna be pretty nuts like everybody
was pretty happy with the narrative of
season one that's why they're going back
to that the way that arrow went back to
season one during season five like
everybody talks about how arrow is so
much better in season five so that's
kind of the vibe that they're giving off
just to make more Cisco puns for season
four of the flash so you see iris
arguing with Cisco in the trailer saying
no we shouldn't bring Barry back we
don't know if he's still alive in Cisco
just refuses to accept that Cisco
reverse engineer sabotage gun pulls
Barry out but then you remember the
whole reason that Barry went in was to
balance the Speed Force so pulling him
out has a couple unintended side effects
that won't play out till later in the
season like the whole thing is just
bringing him back the first couple of
episodes usually that's what happens
this is like hero's try to do something
good but inadvertently caused more
problems for themselves down the road so
who else do we know this stuck in the
Speed Force right now Barry's been
balancing it all this year meaning that
all the bad things that he did that led
to time remnants that led to all the
stuff the reverse-flash was doing on
legends of tomorrow he sort of walked
that back but because they're not
focusing on extra speedsters the first
half of the season I'll explain when I
think reverse flash is coming back and
it has something to do with the big four
night crossover so everybody was
freaking out when we saw this poster of
all the alternate earth X costumes and
it looks very clearly like Barry's meant
to be the reverse flash of
earth even though he's still buried they
were all raised as Nazis so they don't
think of themselves as evil he's like a
less version of the
reverse-flash and his costume is sort of
a mixture of mech armor mixed with his
red fireman's suit that cisco's turned
into the new flash suit in the reverse
flashes yellow suit
the reason this looks a little more
armored is because they're on a more
warlike planet so they're just more
militaristic so that's why it's extra
hardcore so unless the producers are
flat-out lying to us this is as close as
we're getting to the reverse-flash
coming back the first half of the season
but I actually think that legit eobard
thawne will come back during the second
half of the season briefly but again
because they're not doubling down on
speedsters this year I think when he
does come back it'll be a relatively
brief one-off story but the other big
change that you may have noticed is that
because iris is now working inside STAR
Labs with team flash she's not working
at the newspaper meaning that the future
newspaper will have to change again
remember last year house avatar was
trying to kill her in the byline kept
changing like they knew that she was
safe as long as it said iris west-allen
but now that she's not working at the
newspaper anymore she wouldn't be the
person to write that article so it's
changing anyway which seems kind of
weird so the only explainer that I have
for that now is that maybe at some point
between now and when this article was
written she goes back to the newspaper
so she might not permanently be working
inside team flash here but the other
really big thing that the producers
revealed is that the thinker doesn't
hate Barry like the other villains have
hated him in the past they don't want to
kill him he doesn't want to take his
speed he's not like zoom I need to be
the fastest man alive they said that the
thinker actually needs Barry and wants
to use him to achieve his goal of making
the world better but in the way that he
sees fit in the way that villains want
to make the world better like the
kingpin wants to make New York City
better but his idea of better clashes
with Daredevils so the flash obviously
has his own idea of what better is the
thinker has his that's where their
impasse is and obviously the flash can't
allow himself to be used by anybody else
it could lead to disastrous consequences
it is probably a spin on the thinker arc
from the Wally West Geoff Johns era now
that was a little bit different like he
just
one of the Flash's brain so that he
could expand his processing power but
the thinker probably just wants access
to Barry to get access to the Speed
Force so that he can solve all the
world's problems instantaneously like
imagine if you're a gorilla grodd like
you could control everybody make
everything better the thinker is like a
different version of that he's not
psychic
but there will be a villain in the
second episode that will be sort of a
warm-up for some of the thinker's
abilities in the way that he can control
technology so he'll probably work up to
that it's not gonna be exactly like it
is in the comics like the thinker from
the Jeff Jones era was more of a cyber
space type villain that was released
after the Matrix movies had come out so
it was more of a spin on the idea of the
matrix but they also said something
really funny about the elongated man so
obviously he's a hero in the comics they
said that when he comes in he just
starts hitting on all the women he's
sort of the odd man out he's not like
any previous character they've had on
team flash so he's not an like
earth to Harrison Wells was but they did
say that he actually will be lying about
where he got his powers from in the
classic comics he reverse engineered
this jingo fruit that gave him his
elasticity so he was a pretty decent
chemist like how caitlin helped engineer
the velocity-9 formula during season two
so when the producers are saying that
he's lying about how he got his powers
maybe he just stole them but it sounds
like it's gonna be a chart I park where
you have an irredeemable person at the
beginning of the season who slowly
learns to use his powers and become a
hero and is inspired by Barry by the end
of the season but in a much less beta
version of the character like HR felt
really desperate for attention at the
beginning of the season so it'll be fun
to see how he alters the dynamic inside
STAR Labs but the other thing is is this
weekend is New York Comic Con so there's
gonna be a whole bunch of footage
dropping you've probably heard that
they're dropping a new Justice League
trailer on Sunday of course I'll do a
video for it but the other big thing
that's coming up that they'll probably
drop a trailer for is runaways I've
gotten a lot of requests for Runaways
videos and I've just been waiting for
that first trailer so that's probably
gonna come on Friday night The Punisher
panel is happening on Saturday so I'll
post something from that but if you have
any other New York Comic Con requests
just leave them in the comments below
and I'm expecting new footage from all
the DC shows next
but I want to start doing a flash and
arrow Q&A like DC TV Q&A again each week
that'll probably be a Friday video so
the first one I do will be Friday after
all the premieres so if you see my Game
of Thrones videos then you know exactly
how those work so the flash ring
giveaway is still happening right now
all you have to do to enter that is just
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video for some strange reason Justice
League tickets aren't on sale but once
that does happen that's what the
giveaway will be for congratulations to
atomic comms you're the winner from my
last video if you are new to the channel
I announce winners in videos I just
literally copy and paste your comment
and stick it in the video there's some
new Rick and Morty that I'll be posting
later tonight you can click here for the
new arrow trailer and you can click here
for more new Rick and Morty thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight